welcome back everybody to C plus plus
Library tutorial my name is Matt and uh
this is episode three in this episode
I'm going to talk about cross-platform
compiling because I did say that that's
what this was cross-platform library at
the beginning but we've only compiled on
windows with this visual studio tool so
anyone could follow along with that
because it's a free tool and it gets you
everything you need but what if you're
using a Mac what if you're using Linux
what Would You Do Well I want to show
you that you take this exact same code
and you just compile it over there
sometimes there is platform specific
code and that's what we're going to get
into we're going to get into platform
specific code and what you need to think
about what you need to do well right now
where we left off I did a few updates to
one of the tests I think I just fixed
something that should have been food too
on the second one so it was uh given a
false flag but that's already there
we'll go ahead and push it I guess
that'll be like a prefix before the
episode essentially okay well as this is
right now if we go look at the code
let's go to our solution Explorer look
at our source look at our look at our
thing we don't really see any specific
window stuff here in these headers it's
all generic we'll say no window specific
stuff here so as this is right now with
no changes needed this should work on
any OS issue we're using cmake now
that's one of the great things about
cmake is this cross-platform it's kind
of like a front end to your build system
that's crops platform is essentially one
of the main points of it for example you
know Visual Studio by default it's going
to want you to make a visual studio
project and if you do that you get a
Visual Studio compiling thing and that's
only going to work on Windows they might
I don't know about Mac and stuff they
might have I don't know what Visual
Studio support on Mac is these days so I
have no idea if you can open a visual
studio project there but I'm pretty sure
you can't on Linux at all so you would
have to convert it to something where
you'd have to manually come up with
compiling commands and it's basically a
real pain if you try to go from like
Visual Studio project and then
cross-platform and that's why we started
with cmake this cross-platform
now
um I think the next thing to do here is
basically to compile this on linux. all
right so over to Linux we go we're going
to use I think WSL now I guess I'll
briefly talk about this I probably have
some videos on my channel but I think
they're big dated there are ways to get
the Linux OS on your machine sure you
can do the classic virtual machine those
are kind of slow and clunky there are
better ways these days in my opinion WSL
windows subsystem on Linux is supported
by windows and you can run a lot of
Linux distros so you can test your
compiler now that way there's also
sigwin
um which I've done videos on basically
gets you a Linux console there's just a
lot of ways to get a linux-like
environment on Windows is the point but
we're going to use WSL because it's the
officially supported one I'm not going
to go over the install of that I do have
videos on it but it's pretty
straightforward and open all right so
I've got a Windows Powershell up I've
already installed WSL all right so we're
in Ubuntu here I can do a print working
directory see where we're at we're at my
home
um I can go CD into my source directory
because I already know I have one let's
see what we got here then I should be
able to pull
uh this this uh public repo that we're
working on here because I don't have it
in my source right now so if we want to
pull it we can just go get clone uh
https
github.com code Tech and tutorials slash
nutrition
and if I've spelled that all correctly
we got it there we go spell it all
correctly
now you want to go off your root level C
make now there's a couple different ways
to do this usually what people do is
they make a build directory they go into
their build directory and then they say
cmake and start the cmake command to set
things up
and you want to say that your source so
Dash capital S is backer directory
that's because we're in this build
directory and then you want it to build
in this current directory well if you
wanted to build in your current
directory you actually don't need to put
anything so blank is fine so this
Command right here will give you the
default cmake stuff and here we go it's
uh finding the gnu compiler
cool that's what we want here
and there are ways with cmake to specify
different compilers and stuff but we're
going with a lot of default so we're
still in the build directory we should
have a make file here that's what it's
going to do on Linux so let's do another
list and see what we got down here at
the bottom we do see we have a make file
right there so we just want to run that
we just run make it builds as you can
see it just did full built all it built
our nutrition library and it built our
tester cool so now if we look in here
again we'll see uh well we have
Foundation let's go into that
change directory to it take a look at
that and there's our live nutrition.a
that is a static library and it's ready
to go you could you could link it to
anything in Linux it built successfully
so it won't work basically done but uh
just to be sure here now if we want to
walk through the code here we can use
GDB now GDB is not installed so we need
to install it cool GDB is essentially
the debugger for Linux
and we're going to get that set up here
that way we can walk through and Linux
and do some debugging and see what's
going on okay so to get the debug
symbols on Linux I don't know what it's
doing by default if you don't specify it
might be something that preset but I
couldn't really tell but essentially you
need to set it to debug by calling cmake
like this Dash D C make build type
equals debug and then standard to your
source so
um yeah this is from that build
directory once again just like before
but now it should have built with debug
symbols so we should be able to run GDB
on it now and see what's going on with
that test you can pass in arguments to
your uh executable that you want to GDB
with this uh args basically by doing
this and passing in what we wanted I was
able to figure out
I use a list command to look at the uh
the actual code put a break point
somewhere put a breakpoint at 10. it's
right here and when I actually ran it
and you press n to get to the next line
I found out that
oh this is still bugged basically this
is supposed to be food two dot calories
Food 2. Salt so we never actually pushed
and did a proper pool the code's fine I
just didn't uh push the code from fixing
earlier there we go now we definitely
have the stuff Let's uh let's just
rebuild
see where we're at we're in uh Source s
let's go back a few directories let's go
into build let's run cmake again we
don't necessarily need to run cmake I
could probably just run make since yeah
let's just run make if you're just
changing code in one of the files
typically you don't need to rerun cmake
um there's a little more to it than that
but that's kind of a general rule we are
in the build we've redone the build we
should be able to run C test and this
time as expected it passes so now we can
confirm that the base test of just
eating food with our nutrition app works
on both windows and Linux but there are
times when you need to do specific stuff
in your code for Windows specific stuff
for Linux so we can just uh we can just
do something a little special here let's
see do I have
I'm not using console out anyway or I
guess we can do it on the test here okay
let's just do it on our test file that's
fine so let's say we'll do a little a
little Preamble on our test all right
and we'll just go hit f
underscore win32 that's windows I don't
know why they choose it like that or why
they do it that way
uh underscore 132 but that's what it is
and you always need an end if on this so
this is a compiler Clause this isn't
um a logical if in your running code
this is a logical if for your compiler
only so your compiler will say okay if
Windows 32 is defined then I do this
stuff and that would be you're running
on windows so we could go for example
me out
running on Windows
see out we need i o stream here let's
just include that real quick
and there's an end F here so we could
see if it's running on Windows because
we'll get that console out now obviously
this is a very contrived example I'm
just kind of showing that you can do it
on different os's and get different
places in your code to run all right so
this gets a little messier than I guess
you would think
um pretty quickly like for example just
just a quick look at stack Overflow and
we find out that like all right well
there's a standard I'm kind of doing it
the right way they don't have a Mac OS
in here but yeah whatever it's probably
it's one of these though but yeah at the
end you can put an else error not
support it or something so if they're
trying to compile on something else but
here here's the majority of them there's
Apple underscore underscore Apple
Sometimes they come in like multi-format
like there's the Linux there's also Unix
there's also Capital Linux there's also
Capital Unix so win32 underscore 132.
it's uh
it's kind of a it's kind of a mixed bag
I don't know I would just pick a
standard and stick with it I guess
because there seems to be a lot that
basically all are the same thing
um but it might vary so I guess the
point here is that you need to like do a
little bit of considering for what's
maybe the most common or best one use it
sounds like it's basically this all
right and then we'll put a final else
here says uh I don't know no idea what
you're running on I guess
not sure what
uh OS sure that's fine enough for now so
we can run it right here yeah let's just
hit this
and this will run it with no parameters
but we should get a running on Windows
running on Windows okay so if we commit
this code let's go ahead and commit it
and then run it on Linux so we should
get the Linux one and then that's
probably good enough to show you that
this actually works do a git pool
got some new stuff there 12 lines sounds
good
um
now since uh still the same files we'll
just add some code all we got to do is
run make again to recompile run our
tester
uh let's run our tester by going to it
rather than running ctest because c-test
won't necessarily show the C out there
it is and we can just run it from here
tester um on Linux you got to do a DOT
slash say run
there we go we got running on Linux from
the hip def on that one here's how you
do these same if deaths but on cmake in
case you need to make some specific on C
make here's someone asking the question
and the basic answer is just do an if
win32 do something if Unix do something
Etc et cetera and there's a bunch more
and there's links here
um just Google the question you'll
probably find it peace out guys have a
good one Happy coding